hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by honey and
we will be reviewing
entrepreneur mama 3 fashionista and
blogger
valeria lipovetsky but first let me tell
you about my sponsor honey
so i think that most of us have spent
the last year in our homes
buying basically everything online i
know i
literally haven't stepped foot in a
store for over a year
so honey is a free internet browser
plugin
that scours the internet for promo codes
for the things that you're buying
and then automatically adds them when
you go to check out
so here's what you need to know you add
honey to
your computer in two simple clicks then
when you're shopping on any of honey's
30 000 supported websites you'll see the
honey pop up
at checkout and all you need to do is
just click
apply coupons then you just wait a few
seconds for it to find a coupon
and voila the price of your cart will
drop
that's it this month i saved fifty
dollars on
wayfarer for some furniture for my son's
homeschool
and thirty dollars on some skin products
for me at sephora
so if you've got a computer you can get
honey on any browser that you use
so just go to joinhoney.com abby
so that they know that i sent you to
check it out
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
i will be talking macros and calories
so feel free to skip that portion if
that doesn't feel supportive
to you in your journey and of course
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on a video
all right so according to my research
valeria
is a mom of three boys who was born in
russia
grew up in israel and then moved to
canada at the age of 19.
she worked as a full-time model
throughout her teens
and then went to holistic nutrition
school once she moved here to canada
so valeria's content used to be very
nutrition focused
and has since switched to largely being
a mixture of fashion and lifestyle
with a little bit of nutrition content
sprinkled here
and there so the video that i'm looking
at today is the most recent
what i eat in a week video from her
channel
at the time that i'm filming this while
she was vacationing in costa rica during
covet so without further ado let's dive
in
okay first things first is a big glass
of water with lemon
how many influencers do you see every
single day
okay so like most influencers valeria
starts her day with a glass of either
plain or
lemon water when she wakes up and then
she eats about
an hour after that now to her credit she
does kind of poke fun
at the whole influencer and lemon water
phenomenon which
i think you all know my thoughts about
by now so
to valeria's defense she doesn't
reference using lemon water for
weight loss or necessarily for detox
purposes
like most influencers she simply states
that she enjoys the ritual of it
and she feels as though it gets her
digestion kind of
going in the morning she also indicates
that she's not too strict about having
lemon in her water if she doesn't have a
lemon or doesn't have access to any
um but she just enjoys having a big
glass of water bursting in the morning
so yeah all hydration is good hydration
in my books
now i have definitely debunked the whole
lemon water spiel
enough here on abby's kitchen so most of
you guys know
that drinking water with lemon juice for
any reason
other than that you like the taste is
kind of bs
there's also no concrete evidence to
suggest that lemon water helps to
kick start your digestion any more than
plain old
h2o we do need water to help promote
regularity and to get things moving
so i guess if lemon and adding lemon to
it helps you meet your hydration needs
then
by all means like squeeze that lemon in
but like valeria i wouldn't be too
worried that
not having access to a lemon one day is
going to
automatically back you up now in terms
of the actual food
valeria describes a few different
breakfasts that she likes to rotate
so during her week in costa rica that
included things like
whole wheat toast with almond butter and
a banana and a protein shake with vegan
protein powder and almond butter for the
days that she works out
but my favorite breakfast option of hers
was this
um kind of my go-to here honestly eggs
when i do have breakfast
eggs avocado papaya and whole wheat
okay so love this breakfast we've got
protein in the eggs fiber-rich carbs
from the whole wheat toast and fruit
and healthy fats from the avocado
now if she wanted to bump up the
nutrition of her
other breakfast choices i would say she
could maybe add some eggs or greek
yogurt or cottage cheese on the side
for some protein with her almond butter
toast
and if she wanted to turn that protein
shake into a more complete
saturating meal she could throw in some
fruit
or oats for some fiber-rich carbs she
also mentioned
in her video that the almond butter that
she uses contains chia seeds as well
which is really great for getting in
those important omega-3s so
really really great tip but also you
could find them separately and just
sprinkle them onto your toast
all right let's move on to lunch here so
valeria says that she
usually has a lunch with some form of
leftovers from the previous dinner which
as a busy mom i can totally relate to
in fact i almost always cook way more
than i need at dinner just so that i
know that i've got something
balanced to eat the next day so let's
take a look
at one of her lunches as an example this
is the fish
this is couscous so a little carb
and a salad i'm gonna cut some avocado
i'm just gonna add it to my salad
okay love this spread and
there's a lot of really great meals that
she eats throughout the week
to switch it up but she's usually pretty
consistent about including
some form of protein like chicken tuna
white fish or chickpeas a source of
carbs like
couscous or brown rice and then loads of
greens and veggies on the side with some
kind of olive oil dressing
all of these sound great to me and i
also love that she makes a point of
mentioning that she tries to incorporate
a mixture of that fat fiber and protein
into every single meal
and you know any frequent viewer of my
channel knows that i like to call this
trio
the hunger crushing combination now i do
notice that sometimes she occasionally
opts for
a lower carb lunch like one day she has
a
green salad with just some tuna however
she usually
makes up for this calorically by
including a variety of fat sources like
olives
feta cheese and of course a full fat
salad dressing
i have no issue with eating lower carb
at
a meal or even a day or in general if
this is what feels good to your
body the important thing to me is that
this is done from a place of self-care
and not deprivation which to me seems
like the case for valeria
finally let's talk dinner and take a
look at one example
i brought my sauerkraut fermented
sauerkraut very russian
but i have my fish some potatoes
and sauerkraut and if i'll need more
i'll go for a second ram
so basically a lot of valeria's dinners
seem to look pretty similar to
lunch so we've usually got some
combination of protein like fish or
seafood or chicken
and occasionally red meat fiber-rich
carbs like buckwheat or potatoes
and then of course more greens and
veggies i also want to talk about
valeria's
sauerkraut obsession because we see that
come up in a number of her meals
now as a girl of eastern european
descent
i can appreciate that she may need like
a little taste of home
even when living abroad but sauerkraut
is
actually a very nutritious food because
the natural fermentation
yields good bacteria aka probiotics
which we know are good for gut health
and digestion
but when choosing a sauerkraut at the
store i do recommend looking for a brand
that is
unpasteurized and in the refrigerated
section
rather than the shelf-stable varieties
since the bacteria in sauerkraut
is alive and it'll just die off when
it's pasteurized or stored at room
temperature
now seeing as valeria is in costa rica
in this video
she's probably eating slightly
differently than she would at home
but i love that her meals remain
relatively well balanced
even when she is eating out at
restaurants i also love that she's
happy to go back for second portions if
she still feels hungry
and also seems pretty flexible to order
what she's craving
at that moment like pasta one night when
she goes out with her family
okay so now that we've looked at some of
the thieves in valeria's diet
let's talk about stats and trigger
warning to anyone who may find the
discussion of calories and macros to be
triggering
please feel free to skip ahead to this
time stamp
when the section is over okay so based
on my calculations
the caloric needs for somebody like
valeria
would be approximately 2200 calories
this is just a really rough estimation
and then obviously a bit of a range
because i don't know
exactly how often she's exercising or at
what intensity
but given the fact that she does say
she's trying to put on muscle right now
i'm going to estimate that her needs are
probably at the upper end of this range
now also it's impossible for me to know
exactly
how much of these meals she's consuming
like sometimes she says
she could go back for second helpings
etc i don't know
but i estimated that our intake ranged
from about 1300 calories
to 1900 calories on any given day
with an average of around 1700 calories
per day
now of these calories on average we're
looking at
42 from carbs 24 from fat and 34
from protein so nothing there to really
flag or be concerned about when it comes
to macros
she's also consuming adequate fiber
levels and meeting most of her
micronutrient
needs with the exception that she was a
little bit low on calcium on some days
which is not an uncommon one for a lot
of women
so next let's talk about what i really
liked about valeria's week of eating
honestly the girl knows how to put
together a beautiful balanced plate
we are seeing the hunger crushing
combination all over this week
and girl i am so here for that i also
love that valeria opts for a nice range
of protein sources
but it's focusing on a lot of fresh fish
and seafood
since that is what is fresh and local in
costa rica
seafood and fish are really great
sources of protein for heart and brain
health
which research has linked eating more
fish
to lower rates of heart disease and
slower rates of mental decline as we age
so
that's great i also love that she
literally brings
sauerkraut on vacation for a little
taste of home
now i'm not sure how that made it over
the border but hey
if a certain condiment or food makes the
meal more enjoyable to you
then by all means girl i say put that
on everything now while i think that
valeria really is doing an amazing job
with her nutrition she obviously
knows her stuff she is a holistic
nutritionist i did want to offer a few
tips to help support her goals for
muscle growth
and development so in addition to of
course weight-bearing exercise
the most important thing that we can do
to support muscle growth
is to make sure that we're eating enough
so as i mentioned in the stats
it does look like valeria's caloric
intake is potentially
a little short of her needs as an active
young woman
so just focusing on adding some snacks
into her day
may help her meet those needs i would
also say that
like valeria acknowledged that protein
of course is very important
for muscle fiber repair but we really
want to make sure that we're pairing
that protein
with a source of carbohydrates to help
replenish glycogen stores
and drive that protein into the muscle
faster
so i would just suggest to make sure
that her post-workout meal
has a solid source of protein and carbs
so in the case of that breakfast
smoothie adding a banana or so
or some berries would totally do the
trick other ideas could be
some greek yogurt with berries a tuna
sandwich
or some tofu on rice the yogurt actually
would be
a particularly great option since as we
mentioned
she could definitely use a little bit
more calcium in her day
now let's discuss valeria's relationship
with food and her body
i have to say i have become somewhat
cynical when it comes to online beauty
and lifestyle influencers
like i've basically come to expect a lot
of diet culture
and hugely misinformed information
in every video kill me right now but i
was
blissfully surprised by valeria's what i
mean week
i didn't hear a ton of diet culture
language like cheat or clean
and while she was out for dinner with
her family she stated without any moral
qualifiers
hey you know i was craving pasta for
dinner so i ordered pasta
other times when having like a beef
kafta she does say that she doesn't eat
a whole lot of red meat
but hey that was what was already
prepared in the fridge
so she wasn't going to stress over it
the end
she was able to have that little bit of
flexibility
and that is what the decision can sound
like when you have a really balanced
flexible relationship with food it's
honestly as simple as that
i also want to acknowledge that this
video was sponsored by
like a nutrition tracking app called
life some
but she does call out that she doesn't
like a lot of other trackers because the
emphasis seems to be on
weight loss and she's not about weight
loss but that
she uses the tracker to make sure that
she's eating enough to help her
build muscle i also like that she seems
to emphasize the nutrients that she's
adding to a meal
rather than talking about what she's
avoiding
so she talks about the probiotics and
sauerkraut and the omega-3s and chia
seed almond butter
and the healthy fats in her avocado at
lunch
and like i said before she does mention
multiple times
that she's trying to make an effort to
actually eat more so that she can
build muscle in the gym and what it
looks like to me
as a fellow busy bomb of boys trying to
run a business
her priority is probably to fuel her
body and to fuel her life
and not overthink food choices or be
afraid of it
i also came across a video of larius
from 2019
soon after she gave birth to her third
boy in
late 2018. so in this video
titled body transformation after baby
number three
she discusses the immense amount of
pressure that she used to put on herself
after her previous pregnancies to get
back to her pre-baby body
but valeria talks about how after her
third son
she really tried to focus less on the
weight loss
and focus more on how she was feeling
postpartum and also on breastfeeding
and as a model i am sure that is no easy
feat so i have to applaud valeria for
making the effort to shift her focus
towards self-care whatever that
self-care may look like to her
i also watched a recent vlog that she
posted in which she discusses her
thoughts on
her place in promoting body positivity
as a thin influencer so in the video
she references a tick tock that she
posted of herself
in a bathing suit where she showed off
her body in a pose state
to juxtapose against an unposed state
with the message
that things need to move jiggle bump dip
and roll let's take a look
bodies that look like this also look
like this and it is normal
safe and preferable that your body makes
bulges and rolls as it moves around
to allow you the best range of motion
that you can have okay so
valeria not surprisingly got some
negative backlash for the post
and then she addressed it in the video
stating that she
can't necessarily understand or relate
to other people's struggles
but that she too was a victim of being
teased as a young skinny girl
and also had insecurities as a young
model
so that video i created if there is
someone that just feels like her body
is not this perfect thing some comments
just really kind of rattled me
saying that it's not my place everything
that i share with you on social media is
from
my experience they felt like it's a
little disrespectful
now i do want to just briefly comment on
this
this is admittedly a really challenging
topic
so much so that i had to do a whole
video about body positivity
and why i personally don't use the term
for myself
what i will say about this is that even
if you live in a socially desirable body
which
i think we can all agree that valeria
does
you're not immune to society's
unattainable
beauty standards and pressures these
pressures
are probably even greater in the
modeling world so
yeah i get that the struggle is actually
real
and valeria's experience should never be
invalidated
diet culture is clearly so pervasive
that it's totally normal and
not uncommon for models like valeria
to feel insecure obviously that's pretty
messed up but
totally understandable given the state
of things and as a fellow super skinny
lanky kid
i can attest that people are mean to
thin folks too
but as i discussed in my video on the
bopo movement
body positivity was developed to support
and uplift those in marginalized bodies
not people like me or valeria even if we
still have a lot of insecurities about
how we look
i'm sure valeria is trying to actually
spread an empowering positive message to
her followers that like
hey look at me i know you usually see me
looking snatched my bikini
but i have three kids and look well i
have roles too when i said a certain way
but it can also be really discouraging
for
a lot of people whose body will never
look
anywhere near as desirable as valeria's
does
even in its fat state i mean
even i look at those thin girl body
positive memes and instagram posts
and i feel insecure again that's really
messed up
but it's like what marc quiselle
mercedes said in her
medium article that i quoted when she
says
the white hot rage that i feel when
these women tell me to flaunt my body
that i'm still sexy no matter my size
because they're sexy at their size in
the position that they feel
fattest in this is why i personally
don't show pictures of
my body online because while i know that
my body is
far from perfect and all its lumps and
bumps may be a breath of fresh air in
the youtube wellness world
i still know that i have immense thin
privilege
that by social standards it's still a
really good body so
i would encourage valeria to maybe do a
bit of reading to understand the origins
of the body positive movement
and maybe why some people were
disappointed
in her post and at the very least
maybe update her caption with an
acknowledgement of her
own thin privilege while also
acknowledging that
all bodies even really good bodies
are subject to scrutiny body checking
and insecurities
i want to close off mentioning a few
little red flags on valeria's channel as
a whole
even though i felt that the language and
information shared in this particular
what i
in a day or what in a week was
relatively benign
that is except for some references to
one of the
most bogus diets i am aware of food
combining
sad folks can we just put this
to bed if you need a little refresher
the food combining
diet suggests which foods to eat
together
or separately and also what time of day
to eat certain foods
and food groups to help optimize
digestion food combiners
liken your digestive system to like a
car pileup traffic accident
where if you eat one food incorrectly
for another food
it essentially builds up in your gut
somehow and prevents
digestion this is not
true why would you lie yo i ain't lie
why would you lie to us the facts did
change
when i ain't lie you need to tell the
truth don't come at me like that i
wouldn't have to don't come at me like
this
now one of the food combining rules that
i heard in valeria's video
was that she tries to eat fruit first in
her breakfast
because apparently it's digested fastest
let's take a look i'm gonna start with
um
eating the papaya first there's a whole
concept of
food combining or just like a the better
way to eat for optimal digestion uh
no so the thinking behind this is that
because carbs like fruit are digested
faster than let's say
protein-rich foods the fruit will sit in
the stomach
and ferment which will cause apparently
some unpleasant digestive symptoms
folks no first of all fermentation
happens in the intestine
not the stomach and if it was to occur
it would happen regardless of if you had
eggs
with your apple or toast this is more of
an issue with fog maps it is not even
something that you need to think about
if you don't have ibs and are sensitive
to specific types of carbs
but also your stomach actually has a
pretty amazing system for breaking down
the various components of food so yeah
there is no scientific basis to this
intestinal
roadblock situation we actually like to
include a source of protein and fat with
our fruit for the purpose of
slowing down the blood sugar response or
the overall glycemic
load of a meal which can help to promote
longer lasting satiety and energy levels
but again honestly if valeria feels
better eating her breakfast in some kind
of
stepwise order fine cool i mean you do
you
but let's just set the record straight
that there is no
proven digestive benefits to this
practice
food combining bs aside i gotta say that
i really enjoyed
watching valeria's channel i don't know
if i just find her kind of cute and
funny
or it's the fact that she's also a very
busy mom of boys trying to run a
business
and i can just relate but for the most
part her meals look pretty delicious
and her fashion sense is totally on
point so
i get why you guys wanted me to check
out her channel and on that note that is
all for today folks
thank you again to honey for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to
give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
so
you